la mallette Santos
jamais de la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les filles
donc on va te saler comme tu le mérites
j'en ai ras le cul de l'amour j'ai pas
l'impression que ça convienne aux
lesbiennes du 21e siècle pas question
que tu portes ça je viens de sortir du
boulot que moi j'arrive de tous les dos
et ça se voit pas pour autant je suis
pas là pour exhiber la marchandise
je quitte la ville ça tombe bien parce
que moi aussi tu veux aller où toi tu as
la si en Floride ça fait longtemps que
je suis pas heureuse cette virée on va
la faire ensemble mon petit cœur on va
se reprendre en main à quatre mains
livraison de voiture open Sylvanie
m'appelez pas Curly
c'est pas votre nom je m'appelle Curly
mais on se connaît pas pas de
familiarité
on vient pour la voiture attendez vous
avez demandé une livraison à thalassi et
là ces deux gonzesses ont débarqués en
disant qu'elles allaient à thalasser
elle se charge de conduire à votre place
ça vous embête ça se pourrait si elle
tombe sur les colis
c'est quoi on devrait acheter un coup
d'oeil je parie qu'il faut un code
[Musique]
je comprends que vous soyez contrarié
monsieur on va récupérer le colis vous
l'aurez bientôt tout ce qu'on veut c'est
retrouver vos amis
tu sais pas parler aux gens ce qui est
dans la prestation de service peut-être
vachement handicapant et vous ont
retrouvé les détails ils savent qu'on a
leur bazar on peut peut-être leur
revendre les plumer c'est quoi le
problème elles sont recherchées
et je suis flic je te rappelle
qui êtes-vous des démocrates
et ben c'était une grosse journée